I was gonna talk about like Elon Musk oh
yeah ripping our [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] well
if I could drop the track yeah [ __ ]
unbelievable dude he's doing the exact
same thing as us right he is he's he's a
try owning our I was trying it bro yeah
and he wore some [ __ ] Tesla truck
shoes to the met did he really yeah yeah
show me look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] I mean
he'll know the song he Goggins he like
made an EDM song he didn't produce the
round thing growth the lyrics let me
sang it
I received a studio like I refuse to
listen to it I'll make him [ __ ] music
damn those are kind of hard you would
rock these yeah would I hate you
those are hard let's see hmm or is this
a joke just another bit no I don't think
so I think that's real let's go to his
[ __ ] page follow him of course I
followed you all must his Twitter's
hilarious he tweets just like a normal
dude [ __ ] you all right fine
I'll throw my boy a follow yeah it's
[ __ ] relatable CEO I don't buy it I
don't buy the relatable CEO a bit I mean
yeah it is it is a little bit
transparent but I also think that like I
know this [ __ ] load him at least trying
to remain candid on Twitter when you're
like such a powerful person is like kind
of commendable yeah everyone else is
like like Tim Tim Tim Apple Apple
Apple's Twitter you were going that oh
no just for like holidays yeah we wish
everyone a yeah here are the holidays
and and disasters yeah it's wooden eats
about yeah that's written like a [ __ ]
email yeah
twit longer yeah exactly greetings
reading I like to thank everyone at the
whatever yeah
but Elon Musk who's like yo we're at
like 400,000 pre-orders now that's crazy
it's just like super candid I don't know
damn want to thank my fans so much for
blowing up the Tesla truck she just wild
right now we're [ __ ] sold out
shit's insane dude did I had no idea
that the cyber truck would blow up so
hard imagine
next week we're doing more colors we're
gonna have green we're gonna have purple
Elon with the milk boys personality yeah
yeah I do what's what the [ __ ] is good
it's Elon working on some brand new [ __ ]
right now go drop it's gonna be insane
you guys Tesla calm Monday at midnight
it's going off you're gonna want to be
there you're not gonna want to miss it
monday rolls around all right big news
we're putting on a [ __ ] truck tonight
dude tap in make sure you get yours only
[ __ ] limited supply now so you're
gonna want to get a [ __ ] truck dude
look at this dude 50,000 people on the
website right now dude 50,000 and
climbing this is insane my boy is eating
18 sticks of butter right now I'm
drinking 45 beers while this is
happening oh man and check this out
now that we've announced it I can show
you all this sick ass features so come
in here real quick a lot have you been
talking [ __ ] you heard the [ __ ] - is
marble it is but check this out slides
out perfect for doing rails but perfect
for doing rails you can get at least 10
20 [ __ ] lines here everyone can do
coke in this [ __ ] and even better
slide it back pull this out Auto burn a
[ __ ] Auto burning dart pit dude smoke
a dart throw it in here disintegrates it
back you [ __ ] dart toss it in there
and then when you stack it all up and it
burns down you can dump this in the
woods and it's [ __ ] biodegradable and
it helps the environment so you can burn
darts and help them help the [ __ ]
earth dude and craziest thing dude the
bed of the truck is a also we've also
released a full sand mattress so you can
[ __ ] hookers on the road the bed of the
truck is a bad as a bad dude that's why
it's called that it's not for hauling
anything the only thing no you're
definitely gonna haul ass in this thing
because that's what it's for
putting ass in this bed and [ __ ] it
[ __ ] Birds
get yours now hey bud hey bud by the way
this isn't a roast we love the neck boys
yeah the other
vary their characters yeah there's a
great great they've they've been nothing
but nice to us you see Kyle's new house
or the their send house yeah I got a
glimpse and that [ __ ] looks pretty wild
yeah I mean lord knows what's gonna go
on in there dude I don't even want to
think about it
I prefer to think of nelq as the boys we
know off camera I don't like watching
their on camera presidents yeah cuz
they're very different as soon as that
cameras off they're they're so Canadian
yeah yeah they're very just like nice
respectful I would say you boys alright
yeah
can you some water anything yeah thanks
for coming out dude yeah beep what the
[ __ ] is what the [ __ ] is good you guys
why are you smoking a cigarette outside
you know we only smoke them inside
that's was one of their recent bits but
they they got this brand-new house Oh
making Steve smoke a cigarette inside
I'm like well like oh [ __ ] Dart did a
[ __ ] dart I love that phrase for
[ __ ] hacking darts that's the best
one hacking darts it is wild
you